How do bees make honey?
No idea.
To make honey, the worker honeybee sucks nectar from flowers...
...and stores it in its honey stomach.
Once the worker bee returns to the hive,...
...it vomits the nectar into a processor honeybee's mouth.
In the processor bee's mouth and stomach,...
...an enzyme called invertase is added to the nectar.
Invertase breaks some nectar into simple sugars like glucose and fructose.
Then it vomits the partially converted nectar into another processor bee's mouth.
Who also adds more invertase, helping breakdown more nectar.
This process goes on until most of the nectar is converted into simple sugars.
Then the mixture of simple sugars is stored in the honeycomb.
At this point, the mixture is still watery.
Hence, the bees flap their wings which evaporates water...
...and thickens the mixture to eventually form honey.